The Joe Rogan Experience did you see the
uh the new footage his new footage of
Jeremy Corbell leaked in 2021 there was
a battlefield that hovered over an Air
Force Base
it's a lot going on here show the
pictures of the UFO these guys 50 guys
observed this thing corbel thing I'm
trying to process everything he can't
help us
the corbel chili Hormel oh that was a
stretch there you go I didn't know I was
like am I missing that one is that a
cultural reference I'm not sure which
James like because there's articles
about them from Recess
it just came out like a day ago
Instagram that's definitely it check his
Instagram card
whatever this thing is it's they've got
50 different people I I think he
actually released photos of it uh pull
it up jmo does it what about it come on
dude
lights up a billion miles away that's
why it's fun fair if you got a really
good evidence then you would be all in
fair I don't want to be all in I like to
be like half in hey look at that
background I think that's here that's it
we see weaponized that's the craft
that's it
so okay so it's a video so this thing
what this thing is they photographed it
it's half of a football field size and
it was hover over hovering over this
military base and then it just
disappeared just jetted off interesting
50 people saw it 50. yeah who who these
people I'm some military guys who are
these people it's the whole thing is
it's the most exciting thing to me it's
the most fun and all the stupid [__]
that I like to concentrate on you think
they would have been here but I made the
crap when the flares got close the UFO
vanished Into Thin Air well they shot
flares at it it's probably just a
jetliner
oh what
never thought of the [__] CNN
totally that's nothing I mean vanished
Into Thin Air uh you you're dreaming it
probably just shot off at in the same
rate of speed like they always do yeah
how many people would love a full
invasion how about like how about us we
go camping we're doing mushrooms
aliensland I'm dying for a probe put it
up my ass I don't think they do that
anymore I think that's like corded
phones
we have MRIs why the [__] does an alien
need a finger in your ass good point
good point just for fun something to go
tell the friends back at the farm yeah
all these guys that said they got probed
were definitely just sexually assaulted
oh yeah very repressed memories yeah
yeah [__] alien got in there some
[__] Lumber Uncle alien in the forest
yeah right in front of that gay bar yeah
and they're [__] yeah
somehow they're connected
I just did that
son of [__] this guy was on my
podcast yeah this is the dude Travis
Walton from that uh movie Fire in the
Sky did you ever see that movie Fire
Inside yeah he looks like the mic that
guy there's a bunch of witnesses they
saw him get hit with some sort of a beam
they saw a craft land they were loggers
this guy jumps out he's a crazy [__]
lager dude jumps out what the [__] is it
goes running towards it and he gets hit
with his beam he falls down they drive
off they they get like you know half a
mile down the road and they're screaming
at each other we got to go back we got
to go back so they turn around and go
back they go back to the spot and he's
gone five days later the guy shows up
with this crazy story he shows up makes
a phone call he calls the police calls
his family he he said he got abducted by
that craft and they fixed him they said
his body was broken what beam and they
took him aboard and he had these
encounters and there was a movie called
Fire in the Sky
that's a the movies obviously you know
they took a lot of liberties with the
story wow
was it DB Cooper is that the guy who's
in it oh I know exactly that's a
difference yeah doobie Sweeney whoa
right yeah he's the guy that jumped out
of the oh yeah with the money they don't
know that guy that guy's badass that
guy's a nut that guy [__] died of me
that guy two broken legs he was eaten by
dogs he jumped out into the middle of
the woods with no parachute and he
survived I guess the craziest though of
the ass the cows that lose all their
skin oh no no no you're talking about
cattle mutilation yes yeah they don't
know what no explanation turn them
inside out they they cut organs out with
light up like laser Precision They
removed the blood from the body with no
super good methods
there's weird stuff that does happen to
cows what about uh those uh images up
here in uh yeah what the [__] is that
that was a weirdness
Acropolis I think people yay I think
people gave up on that those are dudes
yeah yeah I think people gave up on the
landscapes
well definitely dudes were doing it yeah
yeah but also some of them were a little
more interesting yes there was also they
were they were folded into place in a
way where it seemed like a great deal of
energy was in the like the hospital the
autistic men and they had blown out no
no no they they there's some of them
that they were trying to say like they
had there was a way that you could do
these things but it's very clear when
someone did it that way wow yeah crop
circles
named
intricate patterns carved in fields
across England in the 1980s were a viral
phenomena long before the interest fed
us such prankster Curiosities daily yeah
what these the people that believe that
some of them are they have something
else to them but what about the cows
because that they were good
not one drop of blood cattle mystery not
one drop of blood that's that's the
weird one this sounds like faulty
reporting when they found the cow yay
precisely removed like someone is
someone has cut the organs out of that
cow Oh weird now if it was a person
that's doing it but the way they're
doing it is very unusual no blood come
on yeah I mean I don't know why the [__]
aliens would do that it doesn't make any
sense but it does make sense they're
weird they want stuff they want to learn
a lot of people lean towards humans but
why would they do that the same reason a
[__] alien would but why no blood
what they had the cow blood I'm an alien
want cow blood to learn about our
commercial house yeah yeah you gotta
start somewhere
it was demons but they couldn't quite
they couldn't quite they didn't have the
authority to go after people yet so they
let them have a few cows every now and
then just to keep attacking put it out
they live for thousands of years these
demons and they have to they really just
want to torture they got amazing gut
them and suck their blood out and leave
their [__] little nauseous
dude yeah we're blaming it on Aliens
when it's demons it's just demons demons
practicing they're like okay go take a
cow you [__] freaks
let's go practice for what they're gonna
do to us once they get the green light
once people are like two inexcusably
evil
every country is ruled by evil dictators
well like probably that close that club
a little more sodomy a little more
Unleashed then we find out that Satan's
real is we're gonna get some good
comments after this one the Satan is
real people going writes the reports of
Academy relations began in 1973 mostly
in the west and Midwest it was often
small-scale ranchers who reported them
when local law enforcement agencies
investigated they frequently founded the
cow's ears eyes rectums and sex organs
had been cut away with surgical
Precision according to the newspaper
reports more than ten thousand of the
incidents occurred by the end of the
decade it's demons you're [__] right
dude you're [__] right demons bring
up chupacabras they just have to
practice every now and then even when
they want to they want to do it to
people but but God won't let them yet
yeah right
Jesus Christ dude you're a machine